hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for Nia and in
today's we're gonna be talking about the
crossover event that blades of Persia
how'd it get up that battle pass rank
and all the other items that are within
and how to get those the fastest but
it's always like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe preferred new I covered the
informational side a foreigner that
being the balance changes the here
updates the patch notes in the leaks if
you want to get to today with everything
happening within the world of foreigner
and never miss out on an update don't
free stay subscribe the channel
but that let's get started with today's
video so like I stated the new Prince of
Persia crossover blades of Persia
released about two days ago and after
grinding for about sixteen hours or so
on stream just playing hell of a lot of
Dominion in the occasional breach I'm
about 22 out of 30 ranks into the battle
pass already so I'm pretty close to
being done and I'll probably be finished
by the weekend but after grinding for
hours I discovered how to rank up in the
blades of Persia battle pass really
quickly and also get some of that sweet
cosmetic loot but as we know this year
is a bit different so with this event
specifically there's a battle pass and
of course besides the battle paths with
the stuff in it we get the mask outfits
the weapons and execution ornaments
battle outfits and mood effects the mask
outfit and execution must be bought so
that's out of the question the ornaments
battle outfits and mood effects are in
the past so you can't grind those so the
only thing left is the weapons obviously
you could just get and play any game
mode you want and get the weapons as
long as you have champion status on
that'll help boost your chances those
are really not the harder parts that's
more of getting the other stuff and in
this case there really is nothing else
to get besides the steel that you need
to get the mask outfit in the execution
and then ranking up the battle pass so
as always the first step is the correct
game mode and the correct game mode type
and to that there's a positive and
negative to it so the negative is that
breach got a change to the 2.0 testing
ground version of course if you don't
know what those specific changes are
I'll leave a tag in the top right you
can click on that video it'll give you a
more in-depth changed on what those
changes are for this there's a lot in
that video and I don't want to put it in
this video as that's not the topic so
we're just going to skip that for now
but on the plus side the conversion rate
is still the same after doing some tests
in each of the game modes that I played
earlier I still found out that breach AI
seemed to still be the winner
every case not on a per game basis but
for the long haul
yes battle points are based off time
played so naturally breach would have
the highest because those games go 20
minutes or so the highest individual
game itself is breached PvP because
obviously AI is a lot quicker to beat
than players so adding the longest game
mode in the game with actual players
that's the longest possible thing you
can get so if let's say you know it's
early in the morning you're grinding you
maybe you're going to work or school a
little bit later and you only have time
for about one game afore honor do a
breach PvP game that'll be more bang for
your buck there if you have a bunch of
time two or more games breach AI overall
you get about 150 battle points per game
in one breach game of PvP whereas with
AI it's about 135 so obviously it's less
but two things need to be taken into
account
one is on screen you're gonna be seeing
numbers as proofs that I had achieved
these numbers and you'll notice that
these are a little bit higher this is
because I have champion status and I
don't like counting the champion status
values because not everybody has the
steel for champion status and then like
I said breach AI is good over more games
where as it is just faster than breach
pvp but of course if you have just one
time to play you know one simple game
may be of an order breach PvP isn't that
bad either you could of course if you're
bored I understand breach is a very
tiring game-mode 20 minutes of
constantly playing can be very boring
especially if you keep stacking on those
20 minute games back to back over breach
it can be very boring and I totally
understand that so another thing that
you could be doing is also be playing
Dominion the only issue with Dominion is
that it's about 70 to 80 battle points
per game so not as high but as always of
course if you do get bored with breach
you can always go to Dominion and then
on top of that you definitely do not
want to neglect the daily orders every
24 hours the dailies reset giving you
one that has 50 and another that has a
hundred so making it a total of 150 for
completing them taking this into account
you can easily get multiple ranks in one
day as I stated were two days or it's
about going to be three days by the time
you're seeing this video into the battle
pass for this new event and I'm already
two-thirds of the way done and more so
it's gonna be very very easy for you
guys to rank up and even though it's
less days then there is
ranks I believe there's like 13 to 14
days left in the past but there's 30
tears you have to unlock honestly
setting aside a day or two to just grind
out and have a little bit of fun with
that
it'll be easily caught up in inline with
the time and it should be no biggie
other than that though just as a big
summary I'd like to point out again just
its breach AI is gonna be your better
game-mode if you want to set down for
you know an hour or two or anything more
but of course if you have if you do have
only a time for one game then it breach
PvP is the wave because that per game
like I said it gives more than any other
game mode in the game yeah let me know
if this was helpful for you guys let me
know what your current battle past rank
is and whether that be battle pass and
or event battle paths I'd love to know
what you guys are so far but was always
like to be if you do enjoy subscriber
fee new I cover the informational slide
a foreigner that being the balance
changes to hear updates the patch notes
and the leaks if gonna be catch today
with everything happening within the
world of foreigner and never miss out on
an update that least it's got the
channel that guys take care that girls
today and peace out
[Music]
you